I am a therapist I'm just the skies as
an entrepreneur clouds and dirt is the
thesis that drives my business ambitions
and success when I think about the
clouds it is the mission the highest
level thinking the why where am I going
why and it's the marathon of my
emissions whether that's to buy the New
York Jets or whether that's to be the
open-sourced
entrepreneur the dirt is the work it's
the grind it's the actually doing it
replying to comments with my own two
thumbs it's never getting fancy and
understanding that with all the great
successes I still mean absolutely
nothing
I love the dirt I strive for the clouds
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 273 of the askgaryvee
show right Ryan couple things I'm Andy
and I've been looking at your content
while we're here you have you have two
very seriously consider a Facebook watch
show instead of YouTube it is very
difficult in a heavily mature YouTube to
break out it is very difficult you have
to be disproportionally incredible at
tile images at headlines at
understanding the algorithm and on top
of it be remarkably talented meanwhile
Facebook in its quest to be very
competitive against YouTube and become a
video player is disproportionately
helping Facebook watch shows show up in
news feeds and they're far less people
producing shows on Facebook you have a
supply and demand issue Google Facebook
watch shows learn everything you can and
immediately go all in and create your
Facebook show tomorrow the person that
asks never has the leverage the way you
do it is by listening to me right now
and buying up inexpensive property it's
called Facebook watch it's Malibu 45
years ago I promise you this is what
I've been historically good at
I don't plaques approver and Facebook
and Twitter and Tumblr you know it's for
me to brag about my one skill which is I
can see it a few seconds earlier and it
doesn't take anything you know this I
mean you're you're doing it with me it
doesn't take a rocket scientist we're
just practitioners of our craft just
like you know just like James Tony's
shoulder right it's practicing it will
100% I'm not guessing here you know
everyone's okay you did I'm not guessing
musically I got a love the other day
because I was right it was really big
wasn't like I guessed I'm not guessing
here Ryan here's how you do it you get
to interview the biggest soccer players
in the world when they ask for you to be
on there your show go and build a huge
audience it can be done on Facebook and
when you tell Messi 14 million soccer
fans watch your program I'm a funny
feeling when Messi has a new app
and there you go soccer's one of the
biggest if not the biggest global spore
in the world
there's tons of fans of it even America
gives a crap now obviously the US team
not making it will slow it down but will
not stop it go and create a tremendous
show on Facebook watch hold your breath
and be patient for 24 months and watch
them come to you
we should have a best man yeah talk to
you soon thanks guys
take care what a podcast every Monday we
send out a ridiculous email not only are
we putting original content but a big
strategy mate for me in 2018 it's the
disproportion of surprising delight the
email newsletter you know I don't know
giving away ten porzingis signed jerseys
randomly for the first ten people that
lead to email that day or fly people in
here or lava or VIP if you're in Utah on
the 13th
here's the front row of my speech or if
you're not part of it you're [ __ ] up
it's smart enough to be on the podcast
but if you're not on the email not
complete check it yeah we do
what's up blog get a bunch of meetings
done on my way to Facebook for a meeting
got a couple other calls here I see
Quinn see none more New York jet see him
later Hasan Minhaj you know the comedian
super pumped about that yeah that's okay
that's not discouraging to me nobody
listened to me at first either let me
say it one more time for over a year
nobody watched my goddamn shows on
YouTube the way to be discovered is to
either put out great content to have
piece of content go viral and then
everybody discovers you or become part
of the community you're gonna get
exposure you're gonna get some followers
you're gonna contribute but you're also
gonna learn because you're gonna watch
90 pieces of content doing well on
Instagram Instagram Instagram Instagram
Instagram Instagram
Big Ups heading into December I just
dropped the post right now right now
just a second ago I've never actually
done this I've never jumped on live on
the back of posting something just
moments ago on Instagram but I'm so
ridiculously fired up about the dollar
eighty strategy the dollar eighty
strategy is something that for the
fifteenth for the seventeen hundred of
you that popped up in a minute which is
very nice and flattered I love you I
love you I love you for seventeen
hundred of you the dollar eighty
strategy the dollar eighty strategy is
something that can disproportionately
help you I can't wait to get the email
from you in several months about the
dollar eighty strategy blew up your
social took you to the next level I'm
super fired up go right now right now
right now go to my Instagram profile
leave right here I want the two thousand
of you to leave right now
leave and it leave go to my Instagram
profile and check out the post that I
just made like it tagged a friend who
wants to grow their Instagram a tactical
piece of advice that will work for the
hardest core most disciplined most
ambitious of all of you go check out the
dollar eighty strategy it's real it will
work and for a lot of you that have
under a thousand under ten thousand or a
hundred thousand under a million
followers it works for me it works for
me and it will be the single biggest
reason many of you grow on Instagram
which is your ambition and I love it I
love seeing you guys leave I like the
500 of you left leave right now I want
this 1500 number to go lower leave right
now go to my Instagram leave
leave the livestream leave there we go
1300 leave leave the livestream go to my
Instagram watch the dollar ad strategies
like it comment that share it to tag
some homies leave lead right now best
process leave watch you leave lead or
11,000 I love it leave I want to be here
but myself
Kyle wanna be here by myself me Auggie
and Kyle if I don't anybody there we go
900 lead go look right now let's keep
going down keep go now Knights that
leave Leave leave SIA SIA SIA dollar 80
strategy changing your Instagram game
[Music]
sorry Vlad can't be entertaining busy as
[ __ ] so the first thing you have to do
is realize how young that is and that is
not the normal thing of 27 year old
understands because you're coming from a
world where you're going up and you're
popping out to the real world
like this feels the time like you got to
get your [ __ ] there now you guys I'm
sure thinking about all sorts of things
in life you need to wrap your head
around how young you are you need to get
patient you can not figure listen to me
you can not figure this out for the next
five years wake up and still be young as
[ __ ] you can think about having a family
and like a woman's body I respect all
that but if you're gonna talk to me
about about profession you have a lot of
time like oh you have to understand why
this is the most important thing to
start with it changes everything if you
actually believe me you're putting
pressure on yourself
yeah that's gonna [ __ ] you up that's
gonna make you do [ __ ] you don't want to
do and the fact that you have the
courage to break the system already
makes me ambitious for you because you
already did the hardest part yeah whose
opinion do you value beside your own
here's here's one thing I'll tell you
the truth will always win if you're not
sitting on the couch waiting for his
second contract can't wait that baby's
in a big house cuz my man's gonna do it
well then you will win if you're not
then you'll lose it's super easy so
you'd rather be you know using a
football turn we'd rather be down to you
know the way the Jets are playing this
year it's nice that you're winning in
the going into the fourth quarter you'd
much rather win the game you need to get
macro on this do not make a short-term
decision as long as you know that you're
doing the right thing you will win
keep trying and and you know what the
real answer is you're scared to try the
thing that you might know you want to do
because you're worried about how its
viewed or can you do it I am a therapist
I'm just disguised as an entrepreneur I
think you should do it and I mean
[ __ ] tomorrow so I'll give you I'll
give you some advice I'm good at that
too Google Facebook watch start a
Facebook watch show it's hard to break
out on YouTube too much supply and
demand right Facebook watch is just
starting you can absolutely break out
just eat [ __ ] for three years if you're
good enough to go to Ivy League school
like you've been positively reinforced
for a long time around a game the
problem is it doesn't match what the
[ __ ] you want to do you have to you have
to deploy humility and I don't know how
much humility you have but you need to
deploy humility and you also have to
really get confidence internally
I think it's rad as [ __ ] that an Ivy
League gal wants to do makeup because
it's an interest of yours it's a passion
you're just like [ __ ] do it I will
help you so much if you have the courage
to help yourself I think the biggest
problem right now is you have to have a
real purpose that really matters not the
sake of purpose for the sake of purpose
it's not it's not a wasted to reality
you do this right for three years
nothing good happens but then it pops
and you can [ __ ] get brands paint you
can pay off student loans in the
hundreds of thousands in one year if you
make $400,000 in sponsored posts you've
already quit
which means you clearly are
strong-willed enough to like most people
don't you need to really give yourself a
lot of credit for that you already did
the hard part now you need humility do
you know why most people real
celebrities are indeed [ __ ] they didn't
have the humility to jump on Instagram
when they were gonna have less followers
than other people and so they thought it
was good for them to stay off and now
they're finished you need to have the
humility to put up a video that has 47
please put in the work you don't want to
end up regretful
because you know what's gonna happen
you're gonna be angry at other people
for something you did you're gonna
resent people and it's gonna be a front
it was you that didn't take the jump now
Quincy's mom not the judgment of your
best friend at Ivy League school like
what the fact you have this our
grandparents didn't have this there was
no 92
you know many [ __ ] emails I get from
people homeless single moms at six
okay isn't a [ __ ] layup now we all
have our own [ __ ] right see it's not
perspective you're in such a great spot
take advantage of it if you actually
understood how young I feel and how much
life ahead of me I have you would feel
so different I'm 15 years older than you
[ __ ] younger than I give 27 you're
young [ __ ] as soon as you wrap your head
around that
all of a sudden second take care guys
please don't go to seat you feel better
actually if you answer my make us an
idiot listen listen I'm dead serious I'm
like you have to do it you will regret
it and it will be the worst regret is
the worst feeling on earth please just
[ __ ] do it like what just [ __ ] go
unless you know how to storytelling here
you have no shot period binary oxygen
for anybody in any business let alone
the consumer business that you're in let
alone you guys actually have an
authentic story that once understood is
disproportionately ROI positive so you
have all the upside so you need to
figure it out fast I'm surprised by how
much confusion in marketing there is
between branding and sales and I think
it matters more than ever because this
can do both and it needs to matter my
personal brand has 17 full-time
employees so like you know I'm living it
but I'm also committing financially at a
level that nobody's ever heard I
probably have the single biggest human
production company in the world
I believe proper marketing in the land
that we're going into over the next
decade is disproportionately more
important than finance financial ability
you're gonna spend money on marketing
you might as well spend it
do you know that I'm filming and that
literally this is not a joke in a
hundred years my great-great grandchild
Jeremiah will literally sit in Justin's
seat through VR and actually feel like
they're in this meeting as we speak it
goes so much further what you're talking
about
I was search engine that can depth you
can search when I say the word Jeremiah
literally right now in two months when
this gets documented in there because
there's a lag cuz we don't have a big
enough team you'll be able to search the
term Jeremiah and get right to this
moment not only will we be able to chop
it up into mini documentaries every
single word said by every sin you want
you want to get to truth extremes if you
do that and actually document you build
data behind it it becomes
disproportionately more powerful than
the thing that you and I believe in the
end
seemed like everywhere they'll go hey
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 274 of the askgaryvee
show
Hasan Minhaj is in the building you're
my best friend
oh I haven't put most things on wax
because I don't know about most things
like you know like I'm aware ish but the
thing that I like take enormous profit I
understand what's happening I understand
that thesis I understand twitch I
understand blockchain I understand a ton
of [ __ ] the thing that I think has
really really really worked for me is
understanding the difference between
understanding [ __ ] and being the best at
something
I'd love I'd love to talk more about
twitch and I'm a next year actually this
is around the time when I usually get my
[ __ ] together because I'll go on
vacation in a couple weeks worked a week
or two about four hours into having
downtime I'm like [ __ ] this and I get
crazy and I start thinking about what
like last year like last year during
this December break is what I decided to
give him serious about podcast and
serious about IG I've stayed directly in
my [ __ ] life
[Music]
going into four hours worth of meetings
now one hour piece times four
I've hunted fish so I don't see how that
goes it should be pretty good
get some stuff done
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]